[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
Jada I love you GI Jane two can't wait
to see it
[Laughter]
oh wow wow
wow dude it was a GI Jane joke
[Music]
unless he can flip it in this new tour
he's got to be able to make jokes about
it and there's two types of black people
and then there's Will Smith
it sold out in like seconds oh the only
person
because now they want to see him clown
he should name the [ __ ] Jada you know
what I'm saying
Netflix has officially announced in less
than two months Chris Rock will be
performing the first ever globally live
streamed stamp event held on their
platform almost exactly a year after the
infamous Will Smith slap that took place
at the 2022 Oscars this will be the
first ever Live Comedy event in Netflix
history it'll start streaming around the
world on March 4th 2023 at 10 pm Eastern
while the physical show takes place in
Baltimore Maryland is it enough yeah it
just said Netflix he's doing his hour
live that's the first uh live stand-up
special
he can
seems like every day comedians are
getting more and more Innovative with
how they release their content just a
few months ago Andrew Schultz had a live
release of his latest special but even
that was still more of just like a live
viewing party for an already edited hour
what makes this Chris Rock special so
crazy is that they're going live
basically like a sporting event no
cutting out jokes no multiple tapings or
finding the perfect camera angle this is
going to feel as close to actually being
at the show as humanly possible how was
your weekend
[Applause]
about what happened so if you came to
hear that I'm not I had like a whole
show I wrote before
this weekend
and I'm still kind of processing
what happened like
like I
oh
my serious it'll be funny
the main thing on everyone's mind
heading into March is what will Chris
Rock say about the slap nearly a year
later and still the elephant in the room
every time someone brings his name up I
want to see what the comedy fans thought
of the upcoming Chris Rock special and
potential slap jokes so yesterday I put
in our community section thoughts on the
upcoming Chris Rock Netflix special and
we got some fan responses Brenda said my
long shot guess he doesn't reference a
slap at all it's long odds I know but
how crazy would that be Trevor farted
said I'm sure it'll be good Chris Rock
has always been a great performer and
joke teller I just hope the Will Smith
slap isn't the majority of the subject
matter and this guy said definitely
looking forward to it but let's be
honest that slap revived one man's
career more than her and others
personally I'm gonna have to disagree
with that last comment there I think the
slap really hurt Will Smith and didn't
do that much for Chris Rock I mean I
don't know if he needed any Revival per
se he was hosting the Oscars when it
happened he's [ __ ] Chris Rock I've
reached out to
Chris
um and the mesh the message that came
back is that uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is he will reach out
um
so I will I will say to you uh
Chris I
apologize to you uh my behavior was
unacceptable
and I'm here whenever you're ready to
talk there's also a handful of fans who
have already seen the special or maybe
not seen the special exactly but seeing
Chris Rock performing this exact same
hour on tour Jennifer said Psalm in
December so good some in San Diego in
December couldn't catch my breath from
laughing Eduardo said saw it live at one
of the tour stops [ __ ] great and this
guy said Tom segor saw it live said it
was amazing I'll take his word for it we
went to see Chris Rock yeah that was
awesome you're so happy you were so
happy I was so happy yeah it was amazing
such a great show amazing show he's top
of his game I think so too top of his
game it's crazy as a comedian
who's done this for like a while now
when you realize that all the best
comedians are over 50. you're like oh
you can just keep getting better if you
work at it yeah and I think it's his
best set in 20 years yes of all the
stuff that I think is his best and he
was on
fire yeah and for like an hour 40 on
fire I mean the he kept it up the pace I
was like his energy was crazy there were
so many great takes so many high high
level bits
and he would you know he was just exact
for me exactly what I want to see just
statement provocative you're like
where's this going to go and then just
loaded with jokes it was uh
it was really fun to see I really
enjoyed it so much so did I yeah I
really like his his I won't give
anything away but his
his take on the slap was [ __ ] so good
and so much better than
you know then I would have said or
imagined it's so much you could tell he
took his time with it because it's so
thoughtful it's like a thoughtful
hilarious and he dresses him down in the
in a way that you're like
mm-hmm like it's not just like it's not
roast like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know it's
not blah blah
um it's it's thoughtful and it's layered
and it's um and it's just you know it's
two minutes but the whole I don't know
he's gonna cut that down to 60 first but
it's gonna be an incredible special it's
so good it's so good he's really really
exceptionally good exceptional and like
you said very well thought out very
methodical very thorough you're just
like a couple of bits in there that I
[ __ ] I almost fell over the special
streaming on March 4th at 10 pm and is
titled selective outrage which could be
a shot at canceled culture and how
people are usually pretty hypocritical
with their outrage or it could be some
sort of Nod to the slap personally I'm
not in love with the name I thought
could have been a little bit better
maybe something like GI Jane or that
dumbass bald ass [ __ ] Jada that could
have been good I don't know that's just
me thank you so much for watching this
video be sure to like comment and
subscribe to help out the YouTube
channel and if you want to go even
farther in supporting the joke World
brand go head over to wherever you
listen to podcasts and you know Spotify
Apple download this audio it'd really
help us out in that download metric if I
was being really needy I'd ask you to go
follow us on Instagram and bring them
how we send you free stickers in the
mail if you follow us on Instagram and
fill out that form but I've already
asked you guys to do so much other stuff
in this video I'm not even gonna bring
up the Instagram as far as you know our
Instagram doesn't even exist
but it does it does joke.world on
Instagram we will send you some free
joke World stickers but again I didn't
even say that I didn't even bring that
up okay I'll see you Monday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]